and congresswoman stefanic joins us now
with more you really do you exposed
something that it was a moment that you
don't see often in in Congress three
College presidents three of the most
prestigious universities that gave the
most appalling answer when you were
asking a simple question about you know
anti-Semitism um I'm surprised it took
the the charge of plagiarism to make
this happen what's your
take my take Sean is there is a reason
that the testimony of the presidents of
Harvard Penn and MIT made history as the
most viewed testimony ever with over 1
billion views and that's because their
testimony was morally bankrupt and
pathetic my question was very simple it
was a moral question does calling for
the genocide of Jews con ruin your
school's code of conduct does go against
your school's code of conduct and every
single one said it depended upon the
context we know it does not depend on
the context it should be condemned it is
not that difficult to say that yet all
three failed abysmally and the world saw
it it is unacceptable that it took
Harvard a month to demand the
resignation of Claudine gay Penn made
the right decision immediately but this
is after it was forced in front of the
world to see and I believe these
University presidents sit a top these
institutions that have rotted out and
have institutionalize anti-Semitism
particularly after hamas's terrorist
attack against Israel in early o October
we've seen Jewish students assaulted
physically harassed and facing just vile
V vile attacks every single day well let
me ask you this if if it didn't violate
the code of cont uh code of conduct and
it depends on context would they apply
that standard would they have answered
the question the same way if it was
clearly something said that was racist
uh misogynist xenophobic
transphobic would would would they give
would they have given you the same
answer I suspect the answer is no they
wouldn't say well it depends on the
context they would not
have they would not have Shawn and
that's why it was so pathetic and it was
so clear for everyone who saw that how
wrong that testimony was and I will tell
you what you can't see in the video that
has now been viewed over 1 billion times
is there were Jewish students from each
of those universities who were at that
Congressional hearing and as I was
listening to their responses to my
question the University president Jewish
students you could see them shaking just
of the abysmal lack of moral leadership
and then on top of this you've seen just
the shredding of academic Integrity in
Harvard's case where it was very clear
with this intense scrutiny that claudian
gay was a plagiarist president that she
had plagiarized nearly 50 excerpts in
her work which is a very limited body of
academic work when compared to other
Harvard University presidents and I say
this as a Harvard graduate uh I
graduated from there from undergrad with
honors and I will tell you students if
you plagiarized you're
expelled all right congresswoman Take a
Bow I think that was one of the best um
best moments that I've ever witnessed in
terms of a congress man or woman uh out
there you know being able to uh
literally stump College University
presidents on what was a layup question
uh and they deserve to get fired two
down one to go in my opinion thank you
for being us we appreciate it hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else